he sucks dude I mean his music [ __ ]
sucks donkey balls and the new one is
the actual worst one I listen to two
minutes of that 19 minute song and I was
just holy [ __ ] for Christ's sake our
Kelly admit it it's called hey man you
did it you know so it's called I admit
it it's all about him admitting [ __ ]
it's like it's so annoying that people
think because artists when they're being
honest like it's taken this [ __ ]
stupid turn where it's like oh it's on
people like just like honesty like it
also has to be artistic people are like
yeah but he just bared his soul I don't
give a [ __ ] is it good
did this is what it is on the thing are
Kelly I admit and then impress these 19
minutes song talking about everything
[Music]
I made out and made some mistakes and I
have some imperfect ways I admitted I
have so many people and I'm saying after
the second minute I stopped listen
because it got like it got like he's the
victim you know he's like I admit I have
people around me that [ __ ] up you know I
admit I trust too much it's like dude if
you're gonna [ __ ] be vulnerable just
keep it to your [ __ ] self [ __ ] I
admit that sometimes I go to the wrong
restaurants and they don't they're not
timely with my order
I admit I should be better at picking my
restaurants also his voice is kinda okay
the best singer at any high school in
America is better than him a hey also
his lyrics [ __ ] basic I admit
sometimes when I go car shopping
I get the vehicle with the wrong package
I admit that I dropped out of school he
says yeah all right man
you can google that oh how brave thanks
for admitting that you dropped out of
school because that makes the world
better and then also thanks so much for
letting kids think it will be okay to
drop out of school after you maybe peed
on them just this how long the song
should be four seconds I met I pissed on
14-year old brown that said credits I
admit I had a sex code Brown that's it
by the way I don't think that's that bad
I'm trying to get one oh my god dude
I admit I'm a gift and a curse dude what
do you Batman
I admit I [ __ ] with all the ladies
that's both older and young ladies it is
yeah I have two roots in parentheses I
love always how they put the [ __ ] in the
parentheses you don't have to do that he
said it just put it there too
but tell me how they call it pedophile
because that
[ __ ] is crazy oh well okay I'll explain
it if you [ __ ] someone under well let's
just be conservative seventeen I think
that's the lowest it goes in America and
you're your age then you would call it
pedophilia because well it's pedophilia
it's like looking at a sandwich and
calling it a sandwich oh wow look at
this I did that bump and grind I did
that 12-play I did that fed up I changed
the damn game so I deserve me a fair
play so put some respect on my name fair
oh that is how you know the songs too
long all right first of all it says
verse six okay too long have three
mostly have two if you got a good song
three on a very rare occasion if you got
a banger four but not really because the
DJ could just replay this song if you
got a banger but this is verse six like
it's the Book of Revelations
I admit I love Steve Harvey bye dude
that's what you go I admit it I love
Steve Harvey bye you don't have to admit
you love Steve Harvey I admit I love
Steve Harvey John Legend and Tom Joyner
was that even the last guy is a baseball
player this guy i admit i love john
olerude i admit i love hands Lemieux
Lynn's women show black men some love
cuz black men we go through enough oh
dude yeah alright that's true but don't
take your pedophilia and [ __ ] compare
it to what to the black struggle dude I
made I fondled a girl that's the end of
the song the end play around that's it
that's it it's a [ __ ] 10-second song
oh my god Spotify took me off they
playlist
they you know unbelievable they don't
want me to shine women's group my god
now don't get it twisted I do support
them but why they want to bring down the
are ha you can't be vulnerable and call
yourself the are if your real name is
Robert dude [ __ ] are Kelly dude